et dire qu'il ya trois ans a dit l'amour
ou mady a failli raccrocher les gants
à 32 ans le boxeur élan courtois et face
à son plus grand défi conquérir la
ceinture de champion d'europe des super
moyens
mais ce qui l'attend est presque les
vrais ce de sa catégorie le jeune
anglais james degale champion olympique
amateurs à pékin l'an viii ça va être
dans un premier temps pas forcément de
gagner de gagner ma première envie je
suis parti pour pour fermer deux roule
ses emplois en fermant en emprunts mois
lassé du monde de la boxe amateur il
rencontre antoine farrugia en 2009 à ses
côtés le boxeur il encore toi connaît
une ascension fulgurante des premiers
matches de gala à la victoire en coupe
de la ligue jusqu'au titre de champion
de france il ya quelques mois
tout va très vite pour ce directeur de
centre de loisirs mais il reste les
pieds sur terre
ça reste un plaisir et un sofa surtout
tant que ça reste un plaisir en tout cas
on verra ce soir
moi je compte monter temps je me ferait
plaisir prime et notre plaisir en dans
la salle 1 m 83 pour 76 kg ce boxeur
d'origine comorienne possède un physique
atypique son envie sa rage de vaincre
peuvent rivaliser avec l'expérience du
britannique vainqueur par ko neuf fois
sur ses 12 victoires
moi je pense que l'offre c'est un garçon
complet au niveau box ville a été
champion olympique comme joaillerie et
les champions d'europe
donc au niveau technique tactique c'est
quelque chose de formidable
mais ce qu'il n'a pas c'est ce qu'il a
dans les points parce que j'ai des
copains
enfin des boxeurs avec urban intégrons
qu'on travaille il vise il défend ses
murs donc ça veut tout dire
comprenez s'il est capable de défoncer
des murs il est capable de défoncer un
bonhomme
plus qu'une simple relation entraîneurs
athlètes un rapport père fils lee addy
lie son coach le duo ne se fixe pas de
limite pour l'instant mais il devra
d'abord franchir l'obstacle anglais pour
continuer de se faire plaisir sur leur
image